you have a record stealing a car leading
police on Jason beating a two-year-old
eating two-year-old girl causing body
injury man what's what's that man like
that's not cool everybody it's your
friend Jackie and this week I want to do
a film document I'm on the mega protest
in Dallas of the NRA hey hey no no the
NRA has got to go
it was trending everywhere and the press
was all around the people nor a
convention is coming to Dallas this week
along with the protest tens of thousands
of people to attend and also protest the
NRA convention thousands of convention
goers and they are expecting protests
here as well and I was lucky enough to
get an interview with the organic ATAR
of MGM Monsieur Dominique Alexander the
man responsible for all these people
Monsieur Le Alexandre I like Alex
Alexander Thank You Man and thank you
for taking the time now as a Canadian
Quebec we don't have like the the same
gun issue as here so let's start with
your own organization we stand at a time
where you talked about Trayvon Martin
Michael Brown and all those different
types of things they indicate
was that platform okay for you boys here
in Dallas Texas and the NRA has evolved
into what we call aka national races
Association where it has given a plan
that's what is the name that's what it's
for now oh sorry I'm with sometimes with
the language hey hey no no police
brutality has got to go that's it
man you you let that in Quebec suppose
that never stops welcome sir never okay
okay okay look at these arrows click
with violence and gun violence and mass
shooting in Orlando that's the adora see
the nra fighting against sensible gun
legislation right July 7 2016 Bob Bob
Suter shot five officers wounded back to
the billion and that was the anar and
then guy from the NRA who's shoe
well this guy was a military right he
deals with a lot of mental issues but he
was able to go buy a automatic assault
rifle now if L if you're sick in there
police brutality and guns all right has
got to go see like mental L like for
sure like training or help with people
or like right now like you see like the
guys that criminal can can buy gun like
that like things that can be ground
command do you think that's easier to
start with there are some real
restrictions that guy is making lots of
sense kind of until my cut shop gave me
notes on Mr Al example that piss off
Frankie I know like I was asking I don't
want to cuz I want to make for sure that
Festival but was that that the the
protests were the police were shot it's
in my producer just tell me that was
your organization that hold a damn brick
we
the protest at the end of it we were
pretty much done in a long run me and
the senior that you like that you steal
our car I have a background or whatever
and stuff like that yeah pretty much
call this you attack your girlfriend
like a little girl like 2 years old
you've been that's football size you
paying a joke he's playing a joke so
because like we want to be a responsible
gun but is that true man that you're you
you punch it up take the punch lit up
together there is a lot of necessity but
that's it's see that you have guns and
they said that at that rally yourself
they're organized as you like carry gun
at the at the protest where the police
were shot
no one was no one was get that said
that's a year that people were arrested
not giving their gun and it's see that
you have a record stealing a car leading
police on Jason beating a two-year-old
eating two-year-old girl causing body
injury Danny what's what's that man is
like that's not cool no I don't want I
don't know if we can use that man cuz
like I'm trying to get in the festival
in this that's like you know you have to
tell me that so that kind of thing if
you eat the two-year-old girl and commit
crime like I don't want you to have gone
ma'am ma'am there was so much press I
have to make sure everyone know the
truth amen did you know what the news
that's important the guy who's putting a
ton Dominic Alexander is it a kid a
two-year-old girl is convicted a kid the
two-year-old girl but everyone just
ignores the guy is not actually anti-gun
tillich are the Proteas protest with the
gun is still a car and is attack killed
crack a small kid no one pay attention
not even the members that care about
what people of the NRA how many more
kids in our age
[Music]
outside of the one for Dominic
Alexandra's slap there's more gun than
people in that country right now
elders there's like what maybe 15
protesters there's how many 44 lists
that's almost none there's always
tomorrow
okay there's kids tomorrow okay that's
it tomorrow but I'll make sure that sky
is not here cause I don't want them to
with anybody
there's no real protest going on there's
more people from the media than the
protester and the guy used putting that
on is it's a kid and everyone else at
the NRA seem to be having a good time
yeah maybe you can move with you know
make room F you know you just maybe move
your gun maybe so I'm going to go today
was a bad day no more gun violence no
more gun violence I don't care how
pretty the face you put on them that's
still gun violence
there's no sense nope no more gun
violence maybe we can get rid of gun
violence by just putting a ban on camel
pants see hey Manny
what don't I don't touch and don't shoot
I'm just Kennedy honest scarlis